[Music]
some toys remind you of your best
memories but most of them were created
long ago and there's much more to know
about these toys that you haven't heard
of yet just wait till you see what
popular toy is believed to have been
used as a weapon if this is your first
time visiting our channel don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up today we are showing you
10 kids toys with weird background
stories the slinky your parents and
grandparents probably grew up with that
toy and this is where they wanted to see
you play with it too the slinky is
perfectly simple this spring can travel
down the stairs step-by-step as it
stretches and reforms itself the slinky
can also appear to levitate when you
drop it otherwise it is simply a fun
sensory toy to play with it is always
fascinating to see how it moves with the
help of gravity and its own momentum you
might think that anyone could make this
kind of toy but it took a moment of
genius to invent it during the war in
the 1940s Richard James was working as
an engineer designing new naval
battleships this is when he accidentally
knocked a spring off a shelf and is slid
onto the ground it immediately caught
his attention and he thought that this
could make a great toy he spent the two
following years experimenting with
length and different types of metal to
create the toy that we all know the
reason why it was called slinky is that
his wife Betty saw this word in the
dictionary meaning graceful and sinuous
in the moment she knew that it was the
perfect name for this toy when the
couple went to sell the toy a day before
Christmas they sold 400 toys in an hour
and a half there's still a way to be
happy by having fun with the simplest
things no matter what is happening in
the world the Barbie doll this toy is a
must-have for every little girl and even
boys are starting to play with the dolls
Ruth handler Barbie's mom was watching
her daughter play with paper dolls and
saw that experimenting with the future
was an important part of growing up this
is why she created a doll who unlike any
other ones was a teenager she created a
character that could be anything she
wanted to be who represented the fact
that young women have choices
Barbie already tried out everything from
being a mother a rock star a doctor and
athlete a firefighter and even an
astronaut but there is one other things
she did that she'll never admit the
young girls who play with her Barbie
used to be an adult entertainer
or at least her sister was her
appearance was modeled on a doll named
Lily based on the comic strip character
of a high-end call girl the toy was not
sold to kids but to adult men in tobacco
shops and adult themed stores as a gag
gift
Mattel bought the rights to the doll and
made their own version barbie didn't
keep that dolls heavy makeup but you can
see that she still has Lily's curves and
big breasts let's hope that little girls
won't be inspired by Barbies secret
career or that they will at least be old
enough to make a mature decision if they
ever want to do it the glow stick they
are a must-have at every party if you
want to make things a little more
colorful you can wear them as a necklace
a bracelet around your head or simply
create new combinations you can also
just move them in the air to create a
cool effect but the first people who use
this toy were not actually happy about
it glow sticks were often used for
government or military emergencies after
dark so if you needed to use them it was
probably because something really bad
had happened this toy was created by dr.
Edwin Chandra a professional chemist who
was always curious to find out more
about chemical reactions that created
light instead of heat after leaving
graduate school he experimented with
different ingredients to get that effect
that he was looking for he called a
cheer luck but we know that it was all
due to his attempts however he didn't
fill out any patent for his invention
and didn't think that it would become so
popular but no matter what now we know
that his findings were the inspiration
for the glow sticks that we all use
nowadays dr. Chandra never knew that he
would be the one who invented the most
popular party accessory when he found
out about it he actually laughed and
said that now his granddaughter would
think that he's cool the playing cards
this toy might be cheap and really
simple but there is no limit to the
number of games that you can play with
it and the amount of time you can spend
with your friends you can even have fun
on your own by trying to build a tower
of cards some people even use it to do
magic trick and for witchcraft for more
than a thousand years people have been
finding new ways to play with these
simple pieces of paper with numbers and
shapes printed on it this toy was
actually invented in China before the
Year 1000 and then it reached Europe
around the 13 70s as imports from
merchants the first playing cards were
hand-painted which made them a luxury
good for the richest people King Charles
the six of France was one of these lucky
people who had the chain
to play with it not only the price of
the cards but also the shapes changed
when printing was invented the shapes
had to be simplified to create hearts
spades diamonds and clubs that we all
know today this is also the reason why
they were able to make much more playing
cards and they were soon available for
everyone so even now that we're in 2017
you can still say that you play a game
that used to only be for kings and
members of the upper class the troll
doll we all know this funny little
character with a strange face and
colorful hair up in the air kids like to
create fun stories with them grown-ups
like to collect them and anyone who is
bored likes to play with their hair it
is believed that they bring good luck
but to find out why you'll have to wait
while we tell you how this toy was
invented the toy was created by Thomas
damn and Denmark he was often out of
work and this is when he had time to
carve wood to make these little trolls
he used to give these creations to his
kids but their friends were quickly
jealous so he saw the potential
opportunity to sell them he started
selling some door-to-door then at a
store with his company damn things and
soon he was spending all of his time
carving these funny creatures dan then
switched to making rubber toys in a
factory and by the end of the 50s he was
selling more than 10,000 troll dolls in
Denmark
each year unfortunately he didn't make
as much money as he could as there were
many knockoff trolls on the market the
damn company only won their patent four
decades later but now let's find out why
they bring us good luck the Creator said
that they are so ugly that you can't
help but laugh when you look at them and
when you laugh luck follows you the
Rubik's Cube everyone was confident when
they first saw this cube a puzzle for
children should be easy to solve right
but as soon as we started playing with
it what you could see it was much harder
than we thought
most of us were only able to complete
one face of the Rubik's Cube it takes a
genius to solve this kind of puzzle and
just like us the creator of the toy
wasn't able to succeed either in the 70s
the Rubik's Cube was not created as a
toy but as a working model to help
explain 3d geometry the Creator errno
Rubick called it the magic cube
unfortunately as soon as he started
playing with it he realized he couldn't
solve the puzzle he laughed about the
fact that he was the one who invented a
code but couldn't even
read it and with 43 quintillion ways to
rearrange this cube we understand what
he was going through it took him a month
to finally realize that he had to start
by placing the corners at the right
place to solve it he had so much fun
doing it that he sold the Rubik's Cube
as a toy with more than 350 units sold
worldwide it's still the best-selling
toy of all time for kids and grown-ups
the Cabbage Patch dolls as soon as we
take a look at them we recognize these
little babies with their big cheeks and
frizzy hair they were one of the most
popular toys in the 80s generating two
billion dollars in sales in a decade but
at the start it wasn't about money the
Cabbage Patch dolls were first created
with love but unfortunately its story is
sadder than you might think Martha
Nelson Thomas is the artist who created
these dolls in the 70s people who knew
her described her as one of the sweetest
people they ever met she was always
looking for families and friends to
adopt the dolls the toys were so popular
that she was offered to sell them but
when Martha told a store owner that he
couldn't sell her dolls this man did a
terrible thing he stole her design and
began making his own version and
nowadays Xavier Roberts is still the one
who claims that he created the Cabbage
Patch dolls his toys became widely
successful over the years parents were
even fighting in stores to get this toy
to make sure their children wouldn't be
disappointed for Christmas but no matter
what Martha didn't make any money from
her creation we do like the Cabbage
Patch dolls well we think we would have
liked them even more if they were made
with love
instead of lie the yo-yo every kid
played with this toy at least once in
their life we threw the yo-yo and it
would come back into our hand the best
of us were even able to do a lot of
tricks with this toy but we have to
admit that we couldn't find a way to
make it wind itself back up so we used
an electric one instead the yo-yo was
the only way to have fun but do you know
that it is believed that the yo-yo was
an ancient Filipino weapon there is no
historical evidence that it was used
this way but we still think it's a fun
rumor the toy actually came from the
Philippines but was just used for fun it
was brought to the United States by an
immigrant in the 1910s and he sold the
trademark to the Duncan yo-yo company at
that time many demonstrators used to
tell the
story of the yo-yo being an exotic
weapon but then they started working on
something that was even more interesting
they improved the toy year after year so
people would be able to do impressive
tricks with it and we think that this is
actually a better way to win a war we
will just use a yo-yo as distraction and
everyone will suddenly feel better this
line no matter how old we are we are all
fascinated by the sensory toy as soon as
we put it in our hands we can mold it
stretch it tear it and make it bounce it
comes in different colors like green
blue or pink and we can even add
different things to it like glitter
beets or shaving cream this toy is
really simple but that doesn't keep us
from playing with it for hours but
actually it is not as simple as you
might think
slime is a play material of a
cross-linked polymer made with combining
polyvinyl alcohol solutions with borat
ions you probably don't understand this
and neither do we
this is why it had to be created by a
Nobel laureate called Hermann Staudinger
in the 20s he is the one who worked on
the modern understanding of polymer
science it's because of him that the toy
makers were able to recreate the
experiment the first toys were made with
modeling clay and then we had the chance
to play with them as silly putty in the
50s it's only in the 80s that kids had
the chance to play with the slime that
we all know the first one being sold by
Mattel the first color of slime was
green and it seems like we never forgot
about this because it's still one of the
most popular colors the fidget spinners
this toy is trending in 2017 it is so
popular that high schools had to ban
them because it was becoming a major
distraction in class if you're still
wondering what is so phenomenal about
fidget spinners it spins in our hands
for seconds and that's pretty much it
but no matter what millions of kids and
grownups
all around the world can't keep
themselves from making it spin just one
more time and unfortunately this
popularity and the ban might be keeping
kids who really need this toy from using
it the fidget spinner was marketed as an
antidote to anxiety attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder and autism it was
made to help them concentrate in class
as they
something to do with their hands that
wasn't too distracting the company also
said it was a great opportunity to bring
out that creative genius lying deep
within them even though we don't
understand how this toy could do this
anyway scientists and psychologists
actually said it's more of a distraction
than anything else it doesn't help
people suffering from ADHD if that's the
case the fidget cube might be more
effective so maybe the teachers were
right to ban the fidget spinners after
all do you think it helps you focus or
not don't be shy and tell us what you
think in the comments down below and
that's it for 10 kids toys with weird
background stories for more stories like
this don't forget to watch 10 strange
reasons kid toys were banned thanks for
watching
[Music]